It might seem like men are generally stronger than women, but the truth isn't so simple.
Both boys and girls have advantages and disadvantages...
...that end up evening out to relatively equal strength.
Here's how.
It is true that men are generally taller, heavier and have bigger muscles than women.
Studies have shown that on average,...
...men have over 20 pounds of extra muscle and 30 to 40% more upper body strength.
That's because men naturally produce more of the hormone testosterone than women,...
...which is what helps your muscles grow big.
But girls are much better at fighting off diseases.
Women's bodies make more of the antibodies...
...and blood cells you need to fight off illness much faster than men.
That means on average, girls get less infectious diseases...
...and recover faster when they do get sick.
Now, back to the boys.
Men generally have bigger hearts, lungs and veins known as the cardiovascular system.
That means boys' bodies can keep more energy stored for later.
All that blood flow also helps boys to heal faster from wounds.
But to make up for that,...
...women are likely to have lower blood pressure than men,...
...which means they're less likely to get cardiovascular disease in the first place.
Boys have a smaller chance of becoming depressed or developing an anxiety disorder,...
...but girls are less likely to develop psychiatric disorders.
So, are boys stronger than girls?
Well, if you're just looking at muscle mass then yes, boys are typically stronger,...
...but the science shows us that boys and girls are both strong...
...just in slightly different ways.